[Music]
hey what's up guys i'm kbht here hey
what's up marquez are you getting the
tesla cyber truck
um
no well
all right it's been about 48 hours and
i'm back at the studio and i've been
able to sort of crystallize a lot of my
thoughts that have been floating around
about the cyber truck you may have
watched my initial super quick early
video of it from the event a lot of
people have then after that event i
didn't order one and a lot of people
kept asking me hey wait marquez did you
pre-order the tesla cyber truck and my
answer was usually i don't really need a
pickup truck so no the cyber truck
didn't really change that but
it was really interesting but then of
course you have the test ride which for
tesla is notoriously effective and then
just a bunch more information and images
and videos since that event have come
out a lot of these photos and videos
show new angles of things like the
interior uh the lights in the bed of the
truck and a view from the back seat and
the spacious roof line and even how much
that weird marble countertop looks so
strange in the front i'm not sure still
how i feel about that but it's
definitely still there
twitter user matt landry got a video of
the opening and closing of the rear
hatch so the driver presses a button on
the side and it's pretty cool to see it
basically slot open and reveal the rear
view mirror and slotting clothes will
protect the six and a half foot bed
that's allegedly so strong that you can
stand on it and also elon on twitter has
since confirmed that there will be an
option to make that cover a solar panel
which could regenerate up to 15 miles of
extra range per day if you're into that
so if you're really out in the middle of
nowhere then this could help you get a
couple extra miles which could be useful
it's really cool but it's not the reason
i ordered it though the specs of course
are still right and a lot of people who
did their test drives posted their
videos of them and they were demoing the
dual motor version which is doing zero
to sixties in like four and a half
seconds
so that's definitely faster than most
other pickup trucks and even though
that's about the least important spec
for a pickup you care more about things
like total load capacity and how much
you can tow that is still a fun
by-product of having an electric motor
and they will definitely show that off
so it's fun
but that's not why i ordered it though
and then something pointed out by quinn
of snazzy labs in his video the bed
itself has an l-track rail on the inside
of the bed and then the floor of the bed
there's a bunch of slots that you can
use and these two things together can
make whatever combination of mounting
points you want to tie things down or
arrange what you're carrying in that
huge six and a half foot bed that is
really smart i think they should have
mentioned that on stage it's not why i'm
buying it but i do appreciate a good
modular design also since the event elon
has tweeted at supersaf confirming that
there will be a matte black version of
the cyber truck after people sent him
renders
and um
that's
i i swear that's not why i'm ordering
one look at the end of the day when
people are talking about cyber truck you
inevitably land on
the design just what the thing looks
like
and some parts of it are dope and some
parts of it are weird i actually think
the lights in the bed are pretty cool
assuming you can turn them off
the huge bar light on the front looks
sick and it's actually very functional
on the road and the roof light is more
of just cool looking lights but yeah
it's the angles and the line choices
that make this one of the most
polarizing vehicles i think i've ever
seen there were well over 20 000
comments actually let me just check it's
over 30 000 comments now on the cyber
truck first impressions video and
reading through the comments they almost
alternate hilariously between like this
is amazing this thing looks dope it's
one i'm glad they think outside the box
i'm really happy i want one and then the
others will be this is stupid i hate it
it's the dumbest looking truck ever it's
the worst i think when it comes down to
it it's these two lines here instead of
curves i mean when you look at this
truck there isn't a single curve
anywhere it's all angles and points and
lines
it's kind of like how i draw a truck
when i was like five years old and
didn't know better but the simplicity of
it means it's very different from all
the other trucks that are on the road
right now much more striking and when
you think about it and you take some
time with it the more you realize this
was all on purpose to stand out in a sea
of hundreds of other pickup truck
options this one
had to be different it had to be
striking and it had to stand out in a
way and then they had to really lean
into it unashamedly and really embrace
it to give people a reason to think
about it differently it's the same way
i'm convinced right now that apple
lately
does think about making new product
design choices that are intentionally a
little bit jarring just knowing that the
memes will come but soon enough when
people get used to it it'll be the
reason it's recognizable and even iconic
tesla here is trying to break into a
market pickup trucks that has been
established for decades and it's so
mature that the top five best-selling
cars in america for like 30 years
running are the ford f-150 and a bunch
of other trucks that look like the ford
f-150 here's a really great tweet from
twitter user and research director brett
winton
imagine you're trying to break into a
hundred billion dollar market segment
that is 89 male has stronger brand
loyalty than any other segment and
doesn't give a [ __ ] about your
eco-friendly bonafides that is where
tesla is the point being it's a it's a
market that's not only super mature but
it's super locked in there are literally
millions of people that buy a ford f-150
then five years later
buy another ford f-150 and then
six seven years later
buy another ford f-150 and so if you
come out with a new tesla pickup truck
that looks kind of just like the ford
f-150 and instead of an engine it has a
battery and some motors and a tesla logo
on it
they're not going to buy it just like
they didn't buy the other competition
that kind of looks like it they're just
going to buy another f-150 so after
opening a presentation with a whole
monologue about how pickup trucks have
all looked the same forever which is
totally true they leaned hard into a
completely different look
and never looked back this is why i'm
pretty sure next to model y the cyber
truck could end up being the most
important vehicle tesla makes and in
this tech world possibly the most
disruptive but yeah in these two days
it's grown on me a bit and in the two
years between now and when they're
actually into production and start to
ship the thing it'll be growing on other
people too as i'm recording this elon
tweeted
146 000 cyber truck orders so far these
are from people who didn't even wait for
it to grow on them it's they just liked
it already i still don't think it's
pretty it's definitely not it's more
brutalist but i don't think other pickup
trucks are pretty either it just had to
be
different and i am here for its position
as a disrupter and i guess i'm finally
starting to embrace my position as a
tech reviewer where as this is sort of a
piece of tech i'm on the bleeding edge
of this stuff and i'm investigating it
just to figure out if it's good so i
ordered one
well i put i put down my 100 refundable
deposit that holds my place in line i
can turn into an order when they finally
do go into production but i'm in line
for a triple motor cyber truck
i'm all in so i'm looking forward to
testing this thing and we'll see how it
goes hopefully it's on time along with
the other stuff that we're expecting in
the next two years but that's pretty
much it also if you want to get in on
this merch there's a couple days left of
it to get ordered where it will ship
before the holidays i think nine days
left so link below to that as well
i think that's it okay
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace
[Music]
you